hello welcome to this video playing wi m
or l 40k will go to mark our current
Israeli champion okay never never heard
the name which is got a very very good
Blitzer rating here in five minute
reading playing the terminal ofone those
lines I have absolutely no idea about it
could be painful oh she just goes back
interesting isn't this an idea against
set up like that Oh 94 hmm okay I
probably have to prevent that and takes
Bishop takes isn't isn't a problem I
think in takes Bishop takes the pawn f4
just looks weird of course she can play
em on something like okay just develop
for French structure so she's basically
claiming that she has compensation if I
take on f1 it might well be true but try
to quite believe it what's the big deal
96 King e7 once not that that doesn't
let's not enough don't believe that
I mean why it doesn't have an adult
development advantage she's moving her
nights around quite a bit and I have
very weak the dark squares a very weak
so okay so this is the point mm Knight
f6 and then probably canceling I can
also take first yeah maybe take first
and then see what happens the most
principled movie is f5 f5 and e5 it's
pretty brutal but it's I mean it's the
way to trying to punish wide forward for
what she did and maybe it's possible so
age 6 what is what we're talking about
y'all ready to sacrifice stuff probably
anyway I play this the night on h3 is
just just sucks
noe 5 just forward him all the best way
to use your material is to all the extra
material is not to trade down but to use
it for an attack until this is a good
example and night for 92 g six maybe but
it's just okay this is this is this is
an interesting move and not I didn't
have this on the agenda Queen f7 looks
weird
let's do this Queen age five Queen f7
should be okay and you have 95 I was
thinking covering covering stuff but ok
the Queen the Queen can check that it's
definitely true maybe Knight f6 now G
695 yes this is a good solution it's a
very good solution now choose 695 9 h8 I
can take c4 like Quincy for this is good
for black I think the night is not going
to escape I feel I can also play nine
edge route 87
but 995 was my original idn yeah I think
it's good it says it I just think it's
good and I takes h8 and i take c forum
it's better than three takes I wanted to
take with the Queen first but taking
with the night is better intending 93 in
case of cancelling now I think she still
has to take h eight now taking if I this
is basically the same as resigning okay
I still check this quick later Queen
takes is interesting still but I like
the solution it's it's a it's a good
solution yeah night I just thought 93 is
there a problem with this don't see I
don't see one
so Knight g4 is the most forceful way
and then Queenie 525 it's not that clear
actually also castles dance on ok if I
can so long as I intended there is 97 96
f 5 I know that isn't actually time
morning ok
rook takes a tricky one look at 50 be
one Queen the Queen Shaq doesn't really
do that much meat man yeah I think it
still works c4 might be a problem but I
can take with the Queen what's the deal
check I don't see it threatening Queen
f1 checkmate
check
can she take on it five somehow ok so
here f5 hangs I would like to play Queen
d4 yeah this is a technical solution
which I have no time and this could well
be a problem come on that's great yeah
in the middle of a lead of the game you
have no time on the clock getting a
phone call really hate that okay she's
got even less time now check check check
check check white forfeits on time okay
now should have won a hard position of
course not on time yeah kind of kind of
lost the threat yet little Jack my king
g7 was completely winning okay yeah of
course is agitated knew it okay I
probably am winning the night as well
but okay rook e1 so Quincy to is winning
probably many moves windward check I
kind of lost my nerve a little bit yeah
I can't just take [ __ ] won't take all
the pawns of course I'm yeah that was
okay with that got this before God let
never help always
I'm terribly irritated checked okay
check so i would like to look at the
beginning of this game a little bit i
don't i don't really think that this is
all to grade after the after capturing i
think what's in some trouble maybe g3
yeah just to cover it but this is
definitely not a position where this is
making all that sense gay if you like
this for example white struggles even to
Castle him and ok and here she gave up
the pond the issue is simply that I am
pushing the pawns Queen f7 is given by
the engine yeah of course I thought
about the move but I felt I didn't like
to be in this year I thought maybe
there's a tactic here but there is none
and if there is none then this is bye
pretty much winning from black but again
I think that that this solution here was
also pretty good yeah the computer GUI
is that's winning for black now g4 was
even stronger okay didn't quite see the
point I can the engine jack place like
that
okay well then they can this is a little
bit computer ish it looks so yeah it
looks nicer but I think human player
would go for the simple solution and I'm
keeping keeping the minus 3 and stuff
all the way or minus two so where that
wasn't all that bad I just kind of lost
the thread of it ok guys thanks for
watching